let's jump into this first story from
the New York Times New York authorities
prepare for unprecedented arrest of an
ex-president ahead of a likely
indictment law enforcement officials are
making security plans as some of Donald
J Trump's supporters signal that they
intend to protest signal Donald Trump
called for them to protest here's the
video
Robert Costa said steal barricades
arriving outside Manhattan Criminal
Court okay I said District Court of
correct District Court earlier
correction criminal court and uh they're
getting ready for it
I do not believe that they would put up
oh wow he's got a lot of videos of this
holy crap I don't believe they would do
this unless they actually were planning
to indict Trump
because if they don't indict him there'd
be no protest right nothing would happen
this is where I saw like when I was
deciding if it like you know if it's
going to happen tomorrow or not that was
a big indicator do you guys see what uh
MSNBC said when it came to Trump's calls
for for protest they're saying you know
calling for another January 6th yeah
calling for people to pick up arms what
that's that's the way that they're
interpreting it it's like to pick up
arms yeah yeah pick up arms and or
calling for violence easy that's that's
what it is now yeah so just like you
know it's just like what they how they
interpreted January 6. like when they
hear certain words like we're gonna
fight for our country they take it and
make it the most vicious interpretation
oh YouTube does the same thing all the
time I gotta tell people like if they
want to give you a strike and you say
something you got to fight for your red
like whoa oh wow that's the call for
violence these insane standards that
they hold for the right it's it's so
comical to be like 2020 the Riots of
2020. they would do everything that they
could to basically work it down if a
super violent Riot they would work it
down to just being oh it's just some
people there's like a whole parking lot
on fire and that's the standard that the
police station was burning down in the
like fiery but mostly peaceful that's
where the meme comes from like in
Portland at the Marco Hatfield federal
courthouse trying to burn down the
courthouse with federal agents inside
and they're still not reporting on it
all Trump has to say is hey go protests
and that's a call for for Action a call
for violence I didn't hear his call but
what was it like if he gets arrested he
wants people on the streets protests
we need to take our country back which
they also interpret as right it's so
vague like should he be more specific
like be here at this time protest
illegal uh or or unjust arrests of
presidents and things like that I want
to read this real quick sorry uh this is
from The New York Times because there's
interesting framing here to say if
Donald Trump is indicted by a Manhattan
grand jury in the days ahead for his
role in a hush money payment to a porn
star the former president of the United
States of America will be read the
standard Miranda warning he will be told
that he has the right to remain silent
and the right to an attorney these are
among the routine steps for felony
arrests in New York but the other
president the rest of a former
commander-in-chief one who's devoted
supporters once staged a violent attack
on the capitol will be anything but
routine let me uh pause there for a
minute is Trump being charged with a
felony I don't no no my understanding is
a misdemeanor if guilty they're seeing
that as a misdemeanor and that's what
two years that they can go after that
after the Well there must be a mistake
crime that they're talking about let me
let me statute of limitations is like
two years in New York state for a uh
misdemeanor five years for a felony but
they're trying to tie it to campaign
malfeasance Finance malfeasance to take
it off the past the uh that's how
they're trying to extend it past that
five years even because we're talking
about a D.A that's looking at something
that's uh typically if if guilty maybe a
misdemeanor at best but they're trying
to go for not not only a felony but
they're trying to go for a felony past
they are trying distracted with the
felony yeah that's my point because they
said a routine step for felony arrests
is a clever wording trick to make it
seem like he's being charged with a
felony if he isn't you see what I mean
like if I were to say something like I
am going to arrest James here then I
will read him as Miranda writes which is
normal in felony arrests it's like
you the reader then thinks you committed
a felony when it could be like you were
jaywalking and I'm giving you a citation
or something right I mean they just put
the word there so it goes in your brain
exactly you assume that's what it means
no It's Tricky word play it assumes
guilt right away when did this uh
supposed bribe is that what it is for
Stormy Daniels hush money when did it
get paid uh 2016 before the election
that's what they're that's what they're
uh they were talking about I guess it
happened like the action that they're
all talking about happened they were
saying 2006 and then 2016 this hush
money more of like a NDA hush money is
is right people usually say that for an
NDA hush money I don't think so I think
hush money is like when you commit a
crime you know what I mean like if if
someone catches you committing a crime
and you're like I'll give you money if
you don't say anything right hush funny
this is just an ambitious this is like
they hooked up and he's like but don't
tell anybody and I'll and what we come
to an agreement on non-disclosure it's
like it's like a contract right it's
like I'll give you X money in exchange
for X Behavior I don't know if if
there's any how is that illegal well and
a lot of people were also talking about
it possibly being some sort of like
nuisance or hopefully that's the right
phrase payment because 130 000 when
you're trying to win an election if they
were actually oh right for that purpose
right if it was for uh that purpose that
they're arguing 130 000 to a billionaire
seems a little bit low doesn't it she
was going to write a book or something
was the case like if it was the case if
he if he cheated on her or whatever if
he was trying to keep that quiet I
honestly I think they pay more than that
I think it's all nonsense you know if
they can arrest him for this we should
be able to arrest every president right
now look at the tar read allegations
against Joe Biden you've got to look at
the hunter Biden now
so the allegation against Trump is that
he gave some chicky banged money so she
wouldn't talk about it the allegation
against Joe Biden as he slammed Roman up
against the wall and forced himself on
her in the capital in the in the capital
now I'll be uh to be fair it was 30
years ago you're you're going to be
hard-pressed to find any evidence of
this the same thing with talk with um
blasey Ford and Kavanaugh although that
one lacks any credibility so much so
they had to keep calling it a credible
what do they call it a credible
accusation or something yeah incredibly
accused and it was like you're saying
that because it's not like you're you're
saying it over and over again because
the people who listen to you and follow
you are dumb as a box of rocks right
right and you need them to repeat it
because it has nothing credible about a
lady 30 years later lying about
everything and then accusing some like
Boy Scout of being a gang rapist yeah
bringing absolutely zero evidence and
everyone in his life was like oh he's a
great guy at that time like I don't know
and then that other lady was like he
would line up outside of rooms and the
men would all gang bang women and it's
like bro if that happened it would be
like the cover of a newspaper it'd be
the biggest scandal in the college's
history for sure never happened for sure
the reason that presidents tend to
Pardon past presidents when they get out
of office is because you want to avoid
this kicking the ball like what will
happen is if Trump really gets
persecuted and arrested then when Biden
gets out of office and another
Administration comes in they very likely
will arrest Biden for the same kind of
crap and then you'll have a cycle of
arrests and political persecution which
devolves into Anarchy Ford pardon Nixon
right yeah and the long National
nightmare is a way to try to bridge the
gap in all the division and you know
chaos that was going on in the country
and I don't think that's something that
would happen in the current political
climate where like Biden's going to
Pardon anybody I don't know he might
because he talked about this we talked
about this before but the first thing
I'll say Ian is Trump is being
persecuted if he's prosecuted is
something entirely different they've
been persecuting Trump for a long time
just coming after him for anything for
any reason because they hate him because
they're a zombie cult
you know there you go well also I think
it's important to kind of explain what's
going on here with the district attorney
right they've looked into this uh quote
hush money multiple times you this is I
believe the third go at this every other
time from much higher courts they're
saying okay well there's not really
enough to to charge Trump for anything
here now we have a very very Progressive
Soros D.A in Manhattan that's just
saying okay well yeah we'll give it a
shot I'm sure if I get them in front of
a or if I present this in front of a
grand jury we got a good shot at it you
get them get him subpoenaed and force
them in a criminal trial to testify and
we'll get him on something but this is
perjury or something for for this D.A he
has a a record of of downgrading charges
they're they're not uh they're not
Prosecuting what is it prostitution
right now they're not Prosecuting for
resisting arrest or any of that going on
he's a very Progressive D.A that that is
super soft on crime but for this he's
like he's going as hard as possible on a
quote crime that if it were to be the
case it would be six year a six-year-old
misdemeanor but I've I think Biden might
actually pardon Trump well let me let me
let me clarify these are State charges
Biden cannot pardon Trump for State
charges but I think in the event of if
there was a federal case Biden does have
a good incentive to Pardon Trump for the
Optics of we don't play the games that
Donald Trump does when he says I am
instructing the doj to cease this
activity you know we're a nation of Law
and Order blah blah at the same time he
might play the were nation of Law and
Order therefore he must be charged but I
think there's a possibility in a federal
event that Biden would be like I'm the
bigger man look at me I think there's a
lot of people who would reject that who
like Biden and who hate Trump so much
that if he were to Pardon Trump they
would see that as a weak thing for their
side I yeah this is a group of people
that that don't care they want to see
him behind bars are zombies bloodthirsty
right kind of yeah but I don't know if
you call I don't know if you call them
bloodthirsty right they might not know
they are because they're brainless is
what you're saying but they are after
blood regardless it's an interesting
question like
vampires are bloodthirsty quite
literally right and so when we refer to
someone as a vampire it's like a
corporate CEO who's like you know maybe
they're like they're running a big drug
company that's getting guaranteed
contracts to push some kind of
experimental drug in the population we'd
call that person a vampire as like an
insult a zombie I don't know if you call
bloodthirsty you just call
like there's no brain there to have that
it's just it's just chaos and
destruction yeah so we just call them
zombies right zombies don't still need
to eat I don't think they can just stand
there for like a thousand it depends
which you zombies
you know are these the running zombies
which kind of zombie do we got here
they're the voting zombies for sure uh
but I don't know what we need to do is
you got to starve the zombies out by
turning off all social media for like a
month and then just watch them all spin
around confused not knowing who they're
supposed to pretend to be I think it'd
be fun is it irreversible damage though
I don't know if turning it off for a
month we'll even fix it no like a month
later there's just people standing in
the middle of the street their eyes are
white and there's like not moving it's
like well there's nothing there anymore
it's like when Adam and Eve realize they
were human for the first time and that
they were naked in a garden that wasn't
sure what would happen to the zombies
they'd be like oh yeah you're you and
I'm me they're realizing that they can
like think critically by themselves
without being told what to do I will say
I think I think from my personal
experience I think that the left is
author enough right now to where they
they they're just bloodthirsty when it
comes to Donald Trump they don't care
what the consequences are of locking
them up for something that's completely
absurd it's it's it's it's obviously
political persecution right obviously
it's obviously political persecution
persecution but I don't think they care
at all and I don't even think that they
care like I don't think they're thinking
far enough ahead to even see this being
uh a major help to Donald Trump in his
campaign he's already raising money
using this to raise money right now
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time